[Music]
ah
let's start with newcastle they have
finally completed the signing of kieran
trippier you got quite a bit of flack
about being our first money signing oh
no no saying no he's only going for the
money for me it doesn't bother me i had
no more reasons why i came back and
money wasn't one of them if it was i
would have stayed in madrid
four trips towards the end of my career
at tottenham i was going for a tough
patch i was getting hammered i admitted
you know i weren't performing well i
played with players who sometimes need
the arm around them you know and that's
normal did you get that exposed i'm
gonna be honest with you not really who
was manager porch porch yeah
diego simeone like this guy uh is a
legendary manager almost gangsta like
yeah i love him you'd love him did he
have the hairdryer i've seen him kick
off a few times yeah if you argue about
him on the pitch yeah you might be a
world-class player but if you're not
going to run for me you come off after
christmas we weren't allowed to say good
morning that's what the manager said
would say champions and then suarez is
sprinting through just past the halfway
line and obviously he doesn't know
what's behind her but you have marcos
you're insane he's screaming like solo
so you're alone i was praying it was
going to score
and then yeah he put it away and yeah we
won the league
[Music]
you scored a magical goal you became a
hero in that one moment everyone was
like good old kieran trippier a great
feeling to score for my country i know
walker's quick but i don't think i've
ever run faster than him in my life
funny was jason and then we see like you
guys celebrating you know i mean and the
supporters throwing pints in there that
the whole country was
crazy weren't it you know and that's
what we want we want to put smiles on
people's faces
who are the champions of europe what
does it feel like to lose the euro final
i was gutted it was tough to take
because we was there you know penalties
it's easy for me to come out in an
interview and tell everybody what they
want to hear i'm not about that so i
don't want to be playing in the
championship i don't want to go down
somebody thinks they're better than
somebody else or whatever egos you're
not going to succeed in the position
that we're in we all need to be together
we all need to fight we want to stay in
the league but i believe in myself and
the team otherwise i wouldn't be here if
i didn't if we stay up we need to build
and then build again and build again and
then go for the title
[Music]
welcome back to the true jordy podcast
today's guest it's none other than
newcastle and england footballer kieran
tripp yeah incredible cheers thanks for
coming
guys sometimes there should be like
applause there or something do you know
what i mean no but we're not like uh
soccer i am so yeah frankly uh but yeah
it is weirdo to have a an active premier
league football long so we've had like
alan shearer ian wright before and then
to have someone who's actually sort of
still in the game is kind of it's
interesting for us because uh obviously
unfortunately you're in judd uh first
off how are you feeling how's it going
now i'm feeling good um
obviously disappointed with
uh the injury because of the start i had
at newcastle um
it was going for a good moment but these
things happen
i'm positive about the injury
um it's just about fighting now i'm
getting fit because i want to back on
the pitch yeah and hopefully that soon
was it a metatarsal or something fifth
metatarsal so there's a there was a
fracture in there so i had to have
surgery i had to have a bolt in it um
but no like i said the surgeon's happy
my physios are happy
and that's what makes me a little better
what's the normal guideline for how long
people expect to get through different
it's different some some players have
been
six weeks some players have been eight
weeks 10 weeks but obviously it's about
the individual for me now it's just
about supporting the lads you know
getting there getting the points on the
board it's funny with the uh metatarsal
no one really knew what the [__] one was
until david beckham enjoyed his yeah
absolutely and then so you've had quite
an elite injury in that sense you're uh
you're up there with the
defense yeah yeah yeah it's but we see
what happens when they got rushed back
with beckham he rushed himself back from
the world cup and he didn't look the
same so it is about taking your time
yeah it is and obviously i was a bit
young then when when beckham done this
but um
yeah you don't want to rush any injury
back but i've got the right people
around me with my physios at the club
obviously the manager was it the stamp
on you to be honest with you i felt pain
like 10 minutes into the game under my
foot
um and i was thinking i i must have been
stamped on so i carried on and then um
it was getting worse the pain then
obviously the free kick comes off so
i was taking that you know and
half time um i was still struggling so
far i'll give it you know second half to
see how it is then it was that painful i
had to come off but
went for um obviously a scan and i
realized i broke my foot so
i'm guessing when i first felt that pain
i must have must have done it earlier in
the game jesus that's that's mad though
um and it's funny because for me
you know you watch as much football as
you can but like you're someone who
especially in your position as well as a
fullback you guys don't get a lot of the
credit i think only now in in recent
years people have seen the real value of
how impactful a fullback can be but i
didn't really understand how good you
were until you were playing for
newcastle i think a lot of newcastle
fans were the same we knew we were
getting a good player but we were like
this guy's world-class like and i'm not
just saying that because he sat in front
of us i've said it on the kickoff many
times like i guess you go to spain
and at that point it's a bit like out of
sight out of mind but now you're in the
premier league and you're making such a
difference to this team what do you
think you've brought of the the team
that's given such a clear lift my
experiences in spain definitely with the
the experiences out there in the sense
the games i played the manager i was
working for and i feel like the the
position that newcastle was in when i
came here i knew the position that there
was in that didn't scare me um you know
i was ready for the challenge and you
know i've spoke to a lot of the players
i feel like they've you know we've
gelled really well me and my teammates
so i feel that was important but like we
watched your first game and you notice
the difference in the movement of the
ball you notice the difference in the
the structure of the team there is a
different feeling around since they made
new signings so it might not just be you
but there is an overall tone change at
the club isn't there with not only
bringing you in but you can see it
having an impact on the field right i
feel like when you've had that mentality
it's funny because i'm not in the
dressing room but it's just it's coming
through the tv screen where you're like
this guy is a winner and
when you've had a group of people who
have been low on confidence and maybe
not feeling like they are as good as
they can be to have someone come in with
a fresh feel and a fresh mentality and
go no that's come on like it felt like
you did that is that something that
happened or was it just not even said
from since that uh start of the season
they have been going through a difficult
time and
i feel like the manager coming in i
think he's made a big impact obviously
new signings do up not just me you know
the five players that i've came in i
feel like we've added to that what do
you think you've added sorry just like
the leadership you know with bernie as
well you know you see how you sell well
he's been doing and i think sometimes
when new signings walking through the
door it gives you a lift like with me
when i was at a little madrid when i've
seen suarez walk through the door i
think that was assigned a world-class
player here you know and automatically
gives it gave me a lift and i knew you
know we could do something special
especially with him in the side so you
know with other players seeing players
come in it gives you a lift and that's
what i experienced when you are like
looking at it from a outsider's
perspective towards start the season and
you're watching you know you're probably
keeping up on the premier league what
was your perspective of what is going
wrong here did you
um it's hard to say really because have
the lads given you a bit of yeah they
some players talk to maybe about the
the training um
you know obviously they weren't going
for a good patch and sometimes that
doesn't help as players but
i think i heard a lot of time off and
that was one of the main things that
they weren't like the fitness levels and
stuff like that yeah because obviously
the way you train is obviously the way
you play so if you
obviously if you if you're having a lot
of days off and you're not training
right you're not going to perform um so
i think obviously with the gaffer now
obviously i've worked with him before i
know what he demands in training and is
tough
and i think you can see that especially
the leads game you know how they play
the way we
the way we uh match them for the fitness
of course and the playing style as well
you know you've seen the past couple of
weeks now how
the gaffer has tried to implement his
style into the team and i feel like it's
working yeah there was a real like
a frustration from the fans where we
were like we just don't know what our
plan is in playing and
you know like you say with leeds there's
an identity with us now there's an
identity but we were all scratching my
head's just going i felt like just put
the ball to some maximum and hope for
the best honestly and and one thing that
i can't accept was like
um
fitness levels not being where they
should be like
professionalism you know i mean that was
so frustrating for us because you could
see
around that hour mark the team would
just keel over um so it is great when
you see eddie on the training picture
running around like a mad man like
pointing and shouting that you're like
okay he's trying his best whatever
happens you know he's giving 100 what's
that energy like like as a coach well
from when i went first with him when i
was at burnley he demands a lot in
training you know even in the passing
drills he wants 100
every single training session he demands
so much from his players and i feel you
know now especially with my time at
newcastle the players have
bought into it like i said you simply
the performances the fitness levels for
sure uh underpassing out you'll see as
well like yeah you make a really serious
difference than that yeah you know you
you see him he's the type of gaffer he
wants his team to be on the front foot
he wants to be pressing from the front
uh the high energy you see you know joel
joe linden since i've come in he's been
unbelievable that the way he's won the
ball back the way he's played performed
so we felt all the team as well but
that's that's what he wants he wants you
to be aggressive
you see the progress that he's made
since his uh touch charges manager i'm
absolutely loving that attitude change
it like saying hard work it it for us
it's that feeling of well win or lose we
can all go away knowing that the lads
are giving a hundred percent yeah and
you can say it when you say joel in and
like going
and being this battering ram from the
front he's he's turned it around for him
for example in a way that i never
thought he was going to sometimes you
may need that manager
he plays in a different position or
you know
gives you that full of confidence and
you see the way he's performed
especially since i've arrived um he's
been unbelievable
he's powerful
and the way he breaks things up and he
reminds me the way players of musa
dembele want to play with him at
tottenham right yeah he's you can't get
the ball of him he's unbelievable i'm
relieved for him because it it he had
you know some football as they become a
bit of a running joke in the premier
league because he was
spent they spent so much money on him
and we were playing him as a striker as
a left winger it's like
what is this guy supposed to be and yeah
like like a dembele or even a bit like a
i know this guy's the legend but yeah
tori had that same presence and you i
look at him i think if you if you keep
mastering this sort of um style of play
the sky could be the limit for him he he
can go
where he wants to he has the ability to
be a world class player and i think you
know the gaffer has got him in that
position now where
he's like a number eight where he
presses he wins the ball back he you
know
is he's aggressive with with him without
the ball and i feel
you know we're showing that and fair
play to him you know like like you just
said he's maybe come under a criticism
but i think you know he's starting to
show you know what a player he can be um
what about this uh bruno what's his last
gimmick
um what do you guys call him dude's
colin bruno bruno yeah yeah he's uh he's
got he's got a bit of a presence about
um we've seen the highlights on youtube
obviously i like i haven't watched every
game he's played it but be honest right
do you guys go and tune in for the
highlights on youtube and go we've got a
good player here no i i knew of him
anyway before i arrived so sure you did
you watch lego whatever no no no no no
honestly i know of him and i spoke to
the the brazilian lads as well um at
madrid
um and you know from what i've seen in
training as well is
his quality
yeah it's exciting though because
obviously the fans are like saying i
can't wait
yeah but then
as eddie said in his um his press
conference he's like i've got this unit
and that three are doing so well for us
it would be so unfair for for example
for willock to come off the back of his
best performance as i've seen him have
at newcastle what's saint maximin like
because the guy's he seems mad i've
never seen honestly i've never seen
anything like it um
it's i don't know how to explain it
honestly it's mental even in training i
would imagine you're against him
sometimes than training him yeah i'd
just stand off him oh really yeah i'd
stand off him um
we was doing like a possession it was
like a
it was like a 6v6 and
it's he had the ball
he won't pass to anyone like everyone's
trying i'm literally trying to get the
ball off and i'm diving and trying to
tackle him
and he's just one of those players where
like
he just gets you on the edge of your
seat you know the things he does and
honestly i've never seen an honest never
seen anything like him before
i i think there's only one person i
could compare him to
i would actually say uh tierna was
yeah i don't know if you remember this
guy right but when i was growing up we
had tino in newcastle team with shira
unless ferdinand but he was the most
unpredictable person he was also
he's unpredictable off the pitch yeah a
little bit like sense of humor quite
simple he's a politician now do you know
but i'm not surprised he's just a
strange guy but he was um colombian um
but yeah since him it's a maximum the
fans obviously taking him but there's
times where you're saying he wouldn't
pass out anyone
he wants to be a world class player and
he talks about things like a ballon d'or
but in my head i look at him and i go
look who am i but i i think
you see what people like alex ferguson
did with those kind of cristiano ronaldo
type players who want to take everyone
on and
you sort of have to guide that down a
little bit to get the most out of them
so that they do look up and pass is this
something that they're trying to sort of
work on them with or is it yeah and even
i've even i've had conversation with him
since i've been there it's
yeah in games sometimes it's
you look at him against evan for example
he was incredible you know and sometimes
in certain areas
like the one with murphy you know when
he played him in yeah i mean murph was
you know it was a great strike but he
didn't score but yeah there's sometimes
in games where you'll take people on and
yeah he's done the hard [__] yeah
that must like as a fan i'm like oh my
god this guy is like you love him but at
that moment you're like what the hell
are you doing
no sometimes i understand where you're
coming from
but obviously myself in that moment you
don't really i don't think like that but
you have to prefer i'm praying don't
give the ball away
no sometimes in in games um
sometimes when he can just release a
little bit earlier but you know he has
that magic where
he can just make anything happen you
know even i don't know what he's going
to do do with it but
he doesn't want to change that though
the way that how direct he is with the
ball but like i said i've spoke to him
and he's saying to me he wants to you
know win the ballon d'or he wants to you
know play for his national side and
stuff but and he will reach that he will
he has all the ability in the world and
like i said a lot of improvements to his
game like the sense you know just
releasing it to get an assist and little
things like that but
he's a quality player um that everton
game that was it was incredible because
i was like i was having a bit of a moan
about him before and i was like this guy
he drives me mental for 88 minutes and
then you score and then i have to shut
up but in that game it was like yeah
this is the full complete version of you
do you see a difference in him when he
let you know for the everton game could
you have noticed on that day you're like
oh there's something different in him or
does it just happen no i definitely i
definitely see something different and
you go back to the leads game as well
you know he was tracking back he was
working hard and you know i mean if you
want to win these type of individual
awards or play for your national team
these are the things that you're going
to have to do you know and i can just go
back to
even in madrid you know with simeone if
you didn't run you weren't going to play
you know you had to run for a brick wall
for him so and i say to him man i give
him examples with certain players you
know he played for him wingers
and i say you know if you want to reach
the the top you know you have to do
these things and he knows that and he
does do it fair play to him um he
definitely has been doing it no hundred
percent yes since you talk about people
like suarez yeah i mean if louis suarez
wasn't too proud to push from the front
then yeah you no one can be and he does
and he's done his whole career suarez
and
he he obviously knew when he come to
madrid he knows how they work okay might
be different to barcelona but and he did
you know he basically won as a title one
was there last game of the season so
yeah he worked hard and too much you
don't even have a choice when you're
working with simone you have to work
you got quite a bit of flack about being
our first money signing and all of that
uh certain radio stations calling you
out you know so you know i was only
going for the money oh no i know um what
was that like because obviously you know
they're not in your head and you only
you know your true motivation and i know
my reasons why i came back you know to
live back in the north for my family and
and of course the the project as well
you know i've spoke to obviously the
manager the the owners the direction
that they want the club to go in
and it's exciting so yeah for me it was
it was a no-brainer to to come back to
england you got your coffee though
um yeah starbucks yeah posh we've got
the money down here right here uh not
that when you spoil the owner
yeah what was what was that conversation
like with him because he seems a good
speaker
no no very good people um no we're just
talking about you know
the direction that they want the club to
go in we all need to realize this is we
a building process you know the most
important thing for us is staying in the
league this season
um i don't really want to look too far
ahead but um no it's exciting it's
exciting to be involved with the club
what was the main thing that kind of
sold you on their vision for this
they didn't sell it to me and i'm being
honest with you for me
it was the most important thing with
speaking with the manager because i know
him very well obviously i spoke to carl
wilson i'm very close with as well it
was telling me about the club but for me
it was important that my family came
back to the to england especially the
north and for me they didn't really sell
anything to me
being honest with you
didn't sell anything um there must be a
little moment where
you have a realization of
i'm that first signing of a takeover
thing and like there's that it's
undeniable there's something quite
exciting to be about that you symbolize
something for that team and you'll
always be remembered um honestly i'm
being honest with you i didn't really
think of that just excited about the
whole thing come back to england playing
in the premier league
uh what about playing at st james's
because i know there's
i've been there for games and if you're
in the crowd it's incredible but what's
it like being on the pitch and it's a
full stadium now it's not like earlier
on in the season even the cambridge one
it was electric like especially ever in
game uh we went 3-1 up and i even
started the start of the game
bouncing absolutely bouncing and
honestly i've never felt
anything like that really you know you
see how passionate the supporters are
you see the buzz around the city um
and yeah now it's fantastic st james
it's fantastic going back to what was
getting said about you when you signed
yeah you know you picked newcastle um
i'm sure the money there was probably
the same as what it would have been in
other clubs that you could have gone to
and in your head you're thinking about
this is what's best for my family yeah
i've seen your post about uh your kids
and your wife and how important they are
to you and then you've got someone sort
of digging you out
saying
it's for different reasons or not does
did that on any level piss you off
no i didn't it didn't i didn't know i
don't want to swear
no it didn't annoy me um
that was a quote by the way yeah yeah it
was just um for me it doesn't bother me
i had no more reasons why i came back
and money wasn't one of them
if it was i would have stayed in madrid
because you were still wanted simeone
yeah no yeah it said i think she was
staying didn't he no i have a great
relationship with him and
it didn't it's not one of those where it
came out of nowhere he sort of knew
anyway that um if the chance came i'd
like to go back madrid didn't want to
sell a play halfway through the season
they made that clear the manager made
that clear but i spoke to the president
the manager they sort of knew to be fair
that was unbelievable about everything
because in reality they didn't they
could have just said no
so
but to be fair they they was brilliant
with me um and yeah they just wish me
well but like i said the manager didn't
want me to go and
you know it's i had an unbelievable time
though i'm incredible um but the time
was right uh
to come back to england what's it like
knowing that diego simeone doesn't want
you to leave a team that's pretty wide
no it makes you feel good of course you
know you've got one of the best managers
in the world saying he doesn't want you
to go but i had two and a half great
years with him um
something i'll never forget and most
importantly for me i learned so much
more
on and off the field especially when i
when i finished playing
that that was important for me i was
writing all the sessions down for when i
finish
now seriously i'm already thinking about
coaching yeah 100
the fact that you are still wanting to
be around the team despite having an
injury and you're not like yeah lads
i'll see you i'm going i'm going to
dubai for a month or whatever which some
players do
i think is really commendable when the
injury happened i had a good talk with
the manager um and i said like these
things happen you know it's football
even though i can't help on the pitch i
want to be around the the boys in the
dressing room or
the the training grounds you know summer
presence is still there you mentioned
the cambridge game yeah
that was a brutal one
it felt like in my heart that was like
probably going down here because it was
such a you know
such a winnable game and to to like to
lose it the way we did was cutting what
was it like to be a part of the dressing
room after that were you aware of how
because it felt like a dark moment that
one in the cups you know
these games happen you know you've seen
over the years the the the matches that
have been played that
big teams do get beat by
by a league one side league two side and
that's why for me i always respect every
opposition who i play no matter who they
are
and you've seen massive shocks over the
years of teams going out but like i said
the cambridge gamers
we could have been four and a loop at
halftime but you gotta give a lot of
credit to their keeper it was
unbelievable that game um and yeah they
score the goal uh they defend very well
and
at full time you've gotta hold your
hands up and you know you gotta give
your opposition credit cambridge done
well what was the address the dressing
room the dressing was fine obviously the
players after the game was
you know the lads were down you know
but then i was speaking to a lot after
the game not just me but you know uh
jamal as well he was speaking to them i
was saying like
you know
we've got to let this go because watford
is three days away
and we need to focus on that now because
that is a huge game well every game is a
huge game but obviously the situation
we're both filming next to each other
we've got to focus we've got to let this
go now we can't be dwelling about it we
need to we need to push on
how's jamal doing because uh he had a a
really by his own standards i think he'd
probably admit uh it was not his best
season by any means this so far
he came off social media actually at one
point i don't know if you know i didn't
know he came off twitter anyway from
what i understand and
it just felt like the mood around the
stadium had changed towards him like
it's been a good serving but it was like
as fans you're like just don't know if
he's going to be able to carry on for us
when it's going so bad but how how is he
because he's the captain so a bit like
harry maguire's going through a similar
period of man united when you're the
captain you're the center back pressure
is on in it and if you make a mistake
you get punished pretty badly and it's
pretty i've been there no i've been
there when when i was at tottenham you
know the last season i was there it's it
was i went for a difficult moment when i
weren't performing well i i admit that
but now but jamal's good he's confident
he's um you know he's our captain
you know he's a big leader around the
place and he's been performing well so i
need to make that clear that he's he's
turned it around he's been playing he's
been playing really well but obviously
with the past when he's come off social
media i don't know anything about that i
went there obviously but that everton
game for example it was brilliant yeah
the own goal i was like oh god not him
because looking at him at the start the
season didn't go on rocky
but to be fair to the lord she's a great
character an amazing game from him that
was like this is the the lasalles that
we know is in there yeah um and i think
having you next to him and now burn
there
can only we have a great understanding
yeah me and jam like even on the pitch
and like going back to the the ball he
couldn't do it couldn't have done
anything about that yeah one of those
things just hit him and went in yeah you
could do nothing about it but it just
showed great character from him
to keep going
and you know obviously it was an own
goal by holgate but
it would have happened if it wasn't for
him the determination from him and the
way he attacked the ball
you know and we went 1-1 and but he's
showing great character but but now he's
sound
one of the one of the players i'm always
interested in is john joe shelby
because exactly like in terms of talent
there's no doubt he's that he's a
quality player but it's
his career uh it probably hasn't been
fully realized the potential that he has
in my opinion and there was a couple of
years for newcastle where
it felt like he was going to be sold and
now all of a sudden he's rejuvenated and
eddie howe seems to really be getting
the best out of him
uh do you think there's a reason for
that
um
i can't really comment on it on his
his journey for where he was
the to the places in now but
all i can say is players always do
always try to do their best that's a
good one but john joe's had a good
career a very good career and i love
playing with him you know i spoke to
players who have played with him um
you know daddy rosa told me about him as
well um but yeah i can see
what all the hype was about years ago
when he's coming through liverpool and
stuff and even now he's
he's so calm with the boy you can see
that from the career that he's had
um
i think he's a top top player me do you
know what he indicates to me is how much
difference a manager can make to a
player yeah because i think you know not
to put steve bruce down but there were
times where there were questions over
whether steve bruce could motivate the
players it's not your quote that's mine
yeah
and it looked as if the players had to
drop him and technically there maybe
wasn't enough training in those kind of
things i felt personally from there was
clearly like fallings out going on right
off and there was a lot of talk about it
how much do you see that relationship
between what the manager does and what
the how the player's mood are and those
kind of things because you seem like
you're kind of
you know you're always positive for
whether the manager is good or bad or
whether managers you know shouting at
you or whatever but do you see that in
other players and do you see that affect
certain players in different ways it can
do um you know
with with this gaffer coming in um
like you know more than me
with different
different players how they perform from
when the gaffer weren't here until now
i'm guessing you know what joe willock
has been brilliant i think everybody's
been brilliant i think you can see the
standards that i've that i've raised
um he's changed everything the the mood
is totally changed um from what the
players have said and the train and most
importantly the way the train is very
demanding very demanding adio and um
yeah and his training's good as well and
like i said since he's coming you can
see the difference for sure as we're
recording this burnley have just strung
a couple of results together annoyingly
um and it's classic sean dyson or
digging in and showing some grit when
it's time to fight which you got to
respect that um but then also you've got
everton and leeds struggling uh
brentford struggling um and we've
managed to finally get out of that
bottom three
how how are the boys feeling about the
fight ahead and mentally no lads are
feeling good obviously with the results
obviously it helps um
not be only if you know dug some results
out norwich have as well i think that's
gone on the radar a lot of they won
seven points out of
12 or something i think so yeah it's
it's that time the time of the season
and where
you know you've got to dig deep and
you've got you know you've got to keep
pushing do you guys look at the table i
don't really look at the table um
i know we can only control what we do
you know should we talk about uh
atletico then laws yeah i'm kind of
eager to talk about that yeah i think
they're like especially when you were
there they were sort of in a really good
moment as most european managers say you
know when you first went there you were
sort of leaving a situation behind that
what it wasn't like your very peak of
the way people saw you or maybe your
performances as well and maybe those two
didn't correlate what was it like to go
to madrid was there a bit of relief that
you were a bit like i'm away maybe now
from a lot of the
the eye of the english media and i can
just concentrate on football because
like brian said it's a bit out of sight
out of mind with you you know come the
end of the season you're in that la liga
team of the season yeah and everyone's
going well i didn't know it was this
good yeah i mean
because obviously a lot like
it's out there anyway but i was going
for a tough patch um towards the end of
my career at tottenham
and yeah it was some sort of you know
when i knew atletico madrid was
interested in me you know i was buzzing
that's like a fifa transfer isn't it
yeah a lot of people even may say that
um yeah it's like you know tim's on my
comfort zone go and experience it um
what about language-wise not like it was
not at first it was tough by adam morata
burgos the assistant manager at the time
he spoke english and when he went back
to the media side yeah i'll admit it it
was a relief a little bit because i was
i was getting hammered and
you know what i i admitted you know i
weren't performing well your ability to
you it's your it's personal it's two
yeah yeah this is something that is
skills that you've honed for years yeah
so when someone attacks you on it
although they they're not thinking this
is personal to you it probably feels
very personal i just feel you know like
i said before everyone's entitled to
their own opinion i mean i respect that
i have no problem with that but i think
if
it was going it was getting a bit too
far
um that's what i felt justin i agree
just in the sense of
yeah i'm one of them players who
you know i take on the team when i know
i'm not playing well in in that moment
when i wasn't and i just feel like it
was going a bit too fine in the media
sense but again this is was there a lot
of articles and a lot of i don't i
weren't going on social media like you
going on about when you explained to me
about uh
about not going on it and
you know as players you know you know we
are humans as well you know and you know
when players are not non-stop getting
attacked it's yeah it can be tough but
like i said when i had the opportunity
to go to spain and out there it's you
just feel free you know oh really yeah
it was just like
the spanish press quite different yeah
look luckily
they delight me out there you know
you can't read spanish it's great
it's actually doing good don't look at
it pretending i'm reading the paper you
know i'll just see trippier and i was
thinking well yeah yeah he didn't say
mouths or not that's very bad i know i
went what was that obviously
i mean we all want to know diego simeone
this guy uh is a legendary manager and
he has this aura about him of
almost gangsta like yeah you love him
you would love him he's a cool dresser
passionate football man what was it like
the play from and how old is like team
talks and stuff like that yeah to play
for him um
you know
i don't know i admire him
that's what i can say about him the way
his teams defend and um and stuff and
that's what i loved about it that's what
i couldn't wait to to learn off him what
sort of things are you learning sorry
because you're talking about writing
down training sessions yeah no no
yeah yeah the way they train it's
different to english teams the way
in what women just different sessions
it's totally different it's some of the
sessions are like
like
but you're on the goal line for example
and the throwing the ball you want to
sprint up across edit and then dive and
it's just with different training but
it's enjoyable and that's what i loved
about it and the most important thing
for me was the way he approached the
training for the lads that weren't
playing after games he was incredible oh
really and that's why he has so much
respect off everybody uh the way he
keeps everybody happy
so he's not just disregarding playing no
you're still important yeah yeah he is
the clever
we would be on a bike or doing the gym
uh-huh there were players at grafton on
the pitch and he's he's not with us he's
with them you know he's taking the
sessions he's getting involved and for
me
uh to see that
it was it was incredible to be found did
he have the hairdryer did you see the
hairdryer um
yeah i've seen him
i've seen him kick off a few times like
yeah yeah i've seen him kick off a few
how how what kind of not to extend where
he wants to fight you no but like
it's a bollocking there's a long there's
a long um series of things before
fighting as well so there's a lot you
can do before the house i've seen
quicker things
right no but he's um
yeah he is he's dug into players and
he's one of those managers we're like
sorry what would trigger that from him
what to go to to lose it and just start
shouting for example what's his sort of
bug bear that really would make me think
if you argue about with him on the pitch
all right i've seen him drag somebody
off after 30 minutes when i played when
they argued about him so now come off
all right you're not tying into my yeah
yeah you're off shouldn't be there yeah
not necessarily you shouldn't be there
because you can you can learn that
through respect with him talking to him
et cetera but
he's one of those where like yeah you
might be a
world-class player but if you're not
gonna run for me you come off like as a
manager if people aren't investing in
your ideas then
it it renders you pretty useless in that
moment like that's your job so they're
basically challenging your whole
ethos worth to be there right which is
very difficult with diego simeone
because also you know yeah you won't get
in the team right
and also obviously you see the the big
thing is atletico madrid love him so
it's not like you can turn the press
against him or you know someone publicly
will go we hate this guy they love him
that'll be impossible like he's
he's so big out there in spain um
what's it like when you stand on the
sideline and you're the players and you
see him sort of doing that balls thing
he's done that a few times yeah he's
done that a few times what's it like
when you see him do that because he must
be like yeah he's just different
like he's just different like when you
see him on the touchline honestly when
we're training that's how he is in
training
when we're doing passing drills
um i don't know if he's in his
documentary yet he's good yeah you need
to watch his oh wow and they will say
everything about him but even when
you're doing passing drills and the
standard's not good
you know about it you know i mean i've
been on the end of a few of them as well
so i know how it feels i think it's so
important to be able to handle that and
to accept like you need to be mentally
strong yeah he's not digging you out to
try to help me at you he's trying to
make you the best version of you which
is like why you've come to newcastle and
we're all like god this kid's world
class
and it's through hours of that isn't it
yeah it is and i've worked with him
one-to-one
i don't even want to give you a number
but ours just me and him just working
after training it's good that he's got
me into some positions where i
in for a macro i thought i never would
have thought of that the role of the
right back is i mean we see the the
trent alexander arnold
sees james
these kind of players can be now versus
20 years ago when it was
you know gary neville overlapping
beckham was seen as revolutionary and
now it's it's a whole new thing are you
looking at the evolution of your
position and trying to incorporate more
of these things into your game now yeah
i'm always even at the age of that i'm
always wanting to learn i've learned so
much of simeone just even
like when i've been in his meeting room
or in his office and he's got his board
up and he's telling me listen you go in
this position here and he will get lower
near and you know you just think to
himself and when i've actually done it
in the game i think i i never would have
thought that you know and
it's
tactically the genius um
yeah it's
just so much love about him it's quite
creative isn't it in a sense like you've
got to be creative and looking for
spaces and stuff it's weird it's only
like
five yards six yards away from the
opposition
and that makes such a difference these
little these little moments and games
can be a big difference and
um it's not just myself normally you
know you've got people like joao and
the way they're playing now and he's
tactically honest like he's genius when
when he gives you uh it gives you praise
because his standards are so high
how does that feel good yeah it does
feel good because
you know the manager isn't
you respect him
and when he's complimenting you you know
it's coming from him and you just feel
good you know and
yeah he's um and he does that to his
players he
there was one moment where
going for the title and correa missed
the goal um
it was a big moment as well because
madrid just was one point ahead of us
and
the the chance that he missed korea
started she was
it was so close he should have scored
but he didn't and he was crying after
the game
and the manager pulled him
and he'd done a training session with
him and it's in the documentary as well
where
he was working with him on his own where
the balcony took it on his outside of
his foot and toe poked it
and the goal that he scored against
valor de lid last game of the season it
would mimic the exact move he did with
the manager and he scored you know and
he's good like that you know and
yeah he's just good
a really good one-to-one manager yeah i
feel like the best manager has always
come across as all right they can they
can bollock you but also they've got
this father figure feeling to them
does he have a bit of that yeah
definitely and he doesn't he's one of
the managers the way he doesn't have his
favorites
you know he's one of the managers where
he treats everyone the same you know
doesn't matter if
you're luis suarez or karen trippy or if
you're a youth team player it's
unbelievable the kids as well who come
up and he's some players as well his son
trains the foot all the time
good he's a good player really good and
yeah he
on the pitch you won't even think he's a
song because he
he lays into him when when he's not
doing things right so i bet it's worse
for him a little bit yeah i think so i
think so but yeah even on his
documentary you see how you know family
money is you know with his sons and
daughters and
he lived just behind me as well when he
was in spain because we have this
complex and you just see him flying
around on his bike and stuff it's mental
like you know he'll just chat with you
you know playing with like messing about
with my kids and still playing football
with them and that's just type of guy he
is so sorry you're in a complex yeah so
it's like um
you haven't been saying george's park
yeah so saint george's imagine that but
bigger right and it's like center parks
basically
basically right and there's loads of
houses on there with lakes and stuff
like that and that's where like uh i
lived and my teammates and real madrid
players and yeah like singers and you
know right so it wasn't just like uh an
athletic i'm a dream
right you all live near the manager you
can keep an eye on you 50 feet away
you're having a barbecue on a sunday and
he's going two hot dogs there but that's
another thing there's a nice weather out
there and you know one of the boys would
say i want to come around to my house
and you just go out your back gate walk
to his house barbecue wow
that'd be great wouldn't it yeah talk
about the uh the culture of like
everyone's the same yeah i think that's
a really healthy way to manage a
football team i think fans get
frustrated where it feels like it
doesn't matter what someone does in the
eyes of this manager like gareth
southgate for example has been accused
of his favorites it's i we want to see
people pick on form and merit on how
well they're playing do you prefer that
system or do you think some players need
that no matter what you do you're
playing every game
no i feel like some you know some some
everyone's different every player is
different and
you know i i played with players you
know um you sometimes need the arm
around them you know and that's normal
it is but
you know like i said
players are different and but the way
simi only worked it was
you know everyone's everyone's the same
you know
like i said you you we have big
characters in in that dressing room you
know um but yeah like i said a player
needs arm around him you know
once
you know sometimes so did you get that
at spurs when you were going through
your rough patch i'm gonna be honest
with you not really who was manager
porch porch yeah it was more like you
know
i spoke to a few my teammates at the
time and then
we had a great team then great set of
lads
unbelievable dressing room like um but
you know pots don't get me wrong he's
unbelievable manager and
he's done a lot for me of course he has
you know i i respect him that's normal
but i felt like it could have been just
a little bit more you know what i mean
like right
because it felt like
in that scenario
uh towards the end of pocha's time there
you weren't the only one who felt that
way about poach it did feel like he'd
lost the dressing room from the outside
looking in
and now we're in a situation where spurs
players are coming under so much
scrutiny because conte
so soon after arriving has gone
four defeats in five that doesn't happen
to me and
kind of pointed the finger at the
players and going look you've had pots
you've had mourinho and you've now got
me
three pretty world-class managers top
ten in the world and and we're all
having the same problem which is um and
this is the way he's sort of portraying
it in a roundabout way of saying
look i'm not the problem here these lads
mentally just don't have it in them to
do what i'm asking
i guess first off how would you feel
if you were
having the finger pointed at you in the
way those players are know what players
you know we should be giving everything
on the pitch i'm not saying they wasn't
because i know they were um
but obviously he's gonna be frustrated
because you know they put an
unbelievable performance in against
manci well it was brilliant world class
here but you gotta give burnley credit
cause that's no easy place to go
no matter what team you are you know
they'll always give you a good game so
you know obviously he's talking about
full of confidence at the time of course
beating man city and then going into
berlin they lost one nil but
yeah you know the managers obviously has
his reasons obviously i don't know what
they are but he must have his reasons
but
i can tell you the players would the
tottenham players would have been given
100 it's just you know you've got to
give credit to burnley as well because
they're a tough place to go it's a tough
place to play but i guess it's that
point of
four defeats and five for spurs yeah but
the premier league is standard
the premier league's not easy though
like
yeah i've got they've lost four and five
but
the premier league's relentless it's not
easy no matter who you play now like
you've got you've got a battle on your
hands i add content to that and it's
even more relentless that's part of it
you've played under a really
um
a really intense manager in simioni and
a lot of people accuse the likes of um
simeone and uh kante of exhausting the
players like the emotional exhaustion in
there is that possible is that like what
is your reaction to that or do you think
that's just something we see well like
oh he's tired because he plays for
context yeah i think i i don't believe
in that because
like even when i was there
you know we didn't really get many days
off but that's because i was in europe
or whatever uh obviously la liga and
stuff but the way we trained was
we have a guy there like it's called
prophet ortega honestly i've have a look
upon him he is ridiculous like the
training that we did and the way it was
managed the way we train
it was incredible but no i don't really
believe in that right i i don't believe
in that because simeone was relentless
every day
but for me
you know i wasn't getting tired of it i
was
i was excited to be honest with you well
yeah because if someone else is
motivated and and you know given you
that enthusiasm it's infectious that's
where you get the jurgen klopp's in them
who'd push it and push it and push it
and you know
it did work out for you you obviously
won la liga
was that the highlight of your career in
terms of team achievement yeah
definitely i think um
obviously winning the league on the last
day of the season
you know obviously real madrid as well
there was
so if we lost the game uh or even drew
the game and real madrid when we were
down the same points but they would have
won the title on uh head to head
yeah yes would they beat us at their
place
so
when valor delete scored
was thinking oh no way this can't be
happening went one one note down half
time
and this is a good thing about manager
you weren't panicking it was calm you
know it was like
we'll win the game
because after christmas we weren't
allowed to say good morning
that's what the manager said
let's say champions
from christmas
so he set the stall for the players at
christmas so we were about to say good
morning he was like we're gonna be
champions that's all he wanted to all
the physios everybody
all the physios coming in
um every game from from christmas all
wearing let's call madrid shirts the
physios the every staff member one was
walking in there was
there was uh banners in the dressing
room like i said you see the documentary
you'll see it there was banners
thousands like
pictures of you when you was little not
a little things like that and it was
incredible you know and the psychology
of this is fascinating but it does make
a difference absolutely everyone wants
to feel valued yeah and even for the
like i said the players that weren't
playing the players that were in the
squad they all had fall always up there
it was just uh
yeah and winning the last
last day of the
the season career scores and then
yeah and then suarez is sprinting
through and
you know
i i knew i was going to score well i was
praying i was going to score
and then yeah he put it away and yeah
when we won the league if you've got
your
uh you know career hopes and dreams on a
striker going through he's got to be up
there yeah people you back yeah but when
he was spinning through so i don't know
if he's seen the goal so he's just
passed the halfway line and obviously he
doesn't know what's behind him but you
have marcos durense he's screaming like
solo so you're alone obviously suarez
didn't know and he says in his
documentary if
marcos wasn't saying that he would have
took the shot off early
because he's shouting you alone
then you know he took his time and put
it away what was it like when you
you get that medal around your neck you
know you've been you've been working 20
years for this moment yeah and your
champions and and not and there's
something special in my head about you
won la liga but not with barcelona real
madrid yeah so again it's
even more special you could argue how
did that feel obviously i've never won
anything well the trophy will go in my
youth cup medal so that's not bad is it
so uh
yeah no it was it was uh obviously
celebrating with the boys and getting on
the bus because we had to get a culture
about which about two and a half hours
and
it didn't really kick in i i didn't know
how to feel really because it's my first
title it was it was strange
i was buzzing um yeah it was just
overwhelming yeah definitely definitely
overwhelming because it's my first my
first title um obviously playing in
spain i think it started to kick in
really when
you know i come back to england i met
the england team and you know everyone's
come like saying congratulations and
stuff and i feel that's you know when i
took a step back and thought about it
more
was there a law afterwards because some
people describe when you have such a
high that your brain naturally will have
to like come down and write itself again
did you feel a little bit of that or not
no i i didn't personally because when i
obviously won the title and you know
celebrated my wife and kids and then i
met with england literally straight away
oh wow i was buzzing so because i love
going out of england i mean and the
euros was was coming
um
and yes i met the england team so yeah i
wasn't on a low cause i was so excited
to see the boys and uh yeah and train
with them you didn't get the chance to
go around like madrid then you really
just flew away straight away yeah but
when we traveled to uh valladolid there
was thousands of fans who drove all the
way up wow so when we come out
we was going to the bus and you could
see the the support is literally 100
meters away in the car park and then as
soon as he saw rose that was it that the
the police couldn't control him they all
sprinted and then the players just put
for suck it and just sprinted to them
and then yes it was going off like
nice guys incredible no it was good and
then obviously you're going straight
into an england camp which is um you
know possibly one of the most hopeful
england camps i think in our lifetime
right
yeah i mean well we should do the we
should do both of the england
tournaments right involved in because
you played a massive role obviously in
the first
in 2018 so yeah let's rewind to that
because
you
scored
a magical goal it kind of took people by
surprise as well like you like you are
like you're like an unlikely hero that
sort of just pops up within that and now
people are more aware of it obviously at
newcastle right back taking a free kick
though in a tournament like it's not
often that you sort of sit there it is
most people in their mind they go back
to the beckham or that that kind of that
you imagine you became a hero in that in
that in that one moment everyone was
like good old kieran trippier good old
trips though
i think they were the way it went i
think all the players in that in that
group we went to the world cup and you
know they deserve used credit they're
all heroes you know
because it's tough going away to a
tournament and i go back to the players
that say
didn't play
but then when you're going away for so
long that you know it's so important
that we're all together because you're
away for winning the euro things like
five and a half weeks and
you see some players i'll give you a
guys or connor cody was you know yeah i
don't think we played one minute in the
euros for example but he was incredible
around the place all right so positive
trained relentless every day
didn't complain once and you know that
shows a great character that he is you
know he's a great guy anyway but
you need a full team like that and you
know in england after that
yeah the morale and the team spirit
seems nice incredible togetherness you
know it's incredible you said you
watched some of the kickoff highlights
yeah we were highly critical of
southgate because we want to win the
world cup and we think we could have
done and it's it it's frustrating but at
the same time i got to give it up to him
because for whatever whatever he's done
there there's this bond and this unity
amongst you all which in the past i
think pros have admitted if you were a
chelsea player you'd click with them man
united click with them
it wasn't the same way is it is that
right do you think that's different now
100 i think gareth deserves huge credit
from when he took over and until the
position that we're in today you see the
you definitely see the progress is there
from when he first took over like from
my first game against france my debut
from
me being involved from lentil now i see
huge huge progress and there's none of
that united table liverpool table it's
more all right um you know the kit man
will sit with you or yeah whoever all
the staff are mingling with the players
and
that's important i mean and he's and
he's slowly but you know he's done
everything um the real togetherness and
that comes from him you know the
meetings that we've had and you know
what it means to represent england um
you know and to connect with the
supporters as well i feel that is
important you know the players the team
the supporters are you know connected
again and i feel that's happened
going back to that goal well i mean that
was such a meaningful goal in your
career i don't think you'll ever score
anything potentially i mean hopefully
for newcastle when we win the league um
you might never score a goal that's
quite as like shown around the world as
that like that would have been seen by
tens of millions billions probably yeah
yeah these people crazy what was it like
the score yeah an incredible feeling to
be honest with you um
i don't i know walker's quick but i
don't think i've ever run faster than
him in my life when he was jason
no it was a
a great feeling to score for my country
something to to
play for my country is something i've
always dreamt about um i know all the
players say that but they do truly truly
mean that because
it's
one of the best feelings ever um but
yeah to score the goal uh was a best
feeling and the way the game went you
know
we performed especially the first half
of always incredible i think we could
have been freeing a lot yeah sort of
straight freeing a lot but that was the
frustration i think from the fans is
like
we felt like that was that was actually
we didn't get to the final that year but
it felt like that was an easier
potential win of the tournament than
what the showing one yeah yeah for sure
because so many of the big hitters
weren't there
um but croatia were a good side then oh
absolutely like
a decent moderate rocket teacher in the
midfield and just name an itch and it's
there basically basically yeah yeah yeah
the experience
that they've got you know it's
it's like that's what won them the game
can i ask though you know what is it
that means that you're over the free
kicks can no no i don't mean that in a
disparaging way but i mean like how does
a right back from the team end up in
that squad with that talent and they go
yeah i think kieran should take him to
be face
no at the time it was me and young who
was uh hitting the free kicks and
training and
stuff and i just felt i don't know i
just felt confident i just said to young
girl take this one younger so yeah no
problem and i just felt confident um you
know and yeah it's just
if you feel confident and you feel like
taking it like john joe one was playing
leads you know i wanted to take it but
john joe
you know i'll take him no problem you
take it and he scored no you you seem to
have a really good state of mind for a
sportsman like i think it's
it's so i mean we've seen like fighters
like anthony joshua lately seems to be
going through a bit of a love
that is such an important thing in sport
have you worked on that or is this just
something that's just always been there
like i keep going back to it but my
experiences in spain
you know they've changed me completely
changing the complaint and that's from
the manager
like i honestly can't speak highly
enough of him he's that good um
do you mean just just in terms of a
football sense or do you mean
just how does that happen if he's your
football man like you know a lot of
people go to work don't share a lot of
things with her managers clock out five
uh
friday night and i've seen him out of
football loads of times like i said
around the complex where we lived and
yeah i've had conversations with him not
just about football my life in general
because he he's one of manager i mean he
needs to know you he needs to know
everything about you um come on we've
got to sleep together
i love the idea of youtube camping in
the complex
background novel it
is that what you aim for as your own
coach or do you think you like what's
your style of for me it's a team
it's the players that are not playing as
well um
you know make sure everybody's been
treated the same you know there's no
favorites there's nobody who thinks it's
better than anybody else it's people and
that's how you're going to succeed as
long as you're all on the same page
you buy it into what the manager wants
you'll succeed
i've never heard a player come into
newcastle and talk like the way you do
about the team the team the team like
it was in so many interviews on post
match you were like i'm here for my
teammates on and off the field they know
i'm here and immediately the fans were
like this guy's uh he's using his head a
lot like you you do
think about what is the best thing for
everyone yeah and not just about you
and
you appreciate that as a fun yeah but
i'm not
just saying it for just the sake of
saying it i could tell so
it's easy for me to come out in an
interview and tell everybody what they
want to hear i'm not about that so if
you're not all on the same page the
players if somebody thinks that they're
better than somebody else or whatever
egos
you're not going to succeed in the
position that we're in
we all need to be together with the
position that we're in we all need to
fight we want to stay in the league you
know i don't want to be playing in the
championship i don't want to go down
but i believe in myself and the team
otherwise i wouldn't be here if i didn't
so
for me it's you know get our reds down
tomorrow hopefully get the three points
and uh and kick on yeah take a game at a
time it is awkward i've never really
thought as much about it as the way
you're talking about you know because as
fans we just look at who's starting who
am i relying on the day but the vibe
around the club is so important and
obviously as i say at the start of the
season i've never seen it as low as that
in my whole life i think in terms of
like it just felt like there wasn't a
lot of friendliness there amongst the
boys felt quite toxic
it felt like like i say that
from the top down with mike ashley in
the situation that went on there
it felt like
what you're saying about unity and
everyone sharing the same being on the
same page
right from the top down it wasn't like
that has any of any of the lads
mentioned about mike ashley and that
whole era and what he was like and they
haven't gone really into much detail two
minutes i'm not even asked because
that's gone now you feel good no no i
don't mean that in a bad way but we do
yeah but that's in the pasture i mean
yeah yeah never really spoke to anybody
about it it's more
you know what what could happen what you
know how we can
progress you know with the new manager
the the new owners etc so to be honest i
think nobody's even thinking about that
now there's a lot of talk right now
about newcastle got all this money and
we're going to buy this player and that
player on the other
you're obviously
envisaging one point in your career you
may be
a football manager
what what is the sort of thing that
you'd look at now if you were in control
of our transfers in terms of like not a
shopping list but like what kind of
players do you think we should be going
out and buying because i think a lot of
people expect us to go to the robinho
route yeah and the man city thing where
we go and get all these must names and
actually it's been what i would consider
a fairly sensible silence no if if i had
the money i would
do exactly what we've done because
you've got to think of
you know obviously the supporters of you
know like you guys if you've deserved
this you know
they're pushing on now shall we say and
you know it you can't go and buy an
mbappe or whoever you know
we're in the position that we're in so
the signings that we've made you you
know it's you know the characters you
know all five of us that
we've been in this position before where
newcastle are out now
and i think it's good signing clever
signings because we know every single
one of us are going to fight
for the position that we're in so and
it's all about building you know i think
you know and mighty's unbelievable woods
is
you know i know he's not scored but you
know people don't feel think about what
he's doing off the ball he works so hard
for the team it must be hard for him as
well not getting that goal yeah because
it's a strikeout it's what you're judged
on it is no it is
and i understand that but
from what the most important thing for
us players is knowing what he is doing
for us
and he's doing so much for us you know
he's winning his aerial jewels he's
winning the battles he's bringing people
into play yeah of course he would love
to score and then that will come
but what he's doing for us off the ball
the defensive work is he's running stats
not many people look at that but just
try and look at everything that he's
actually doing a lot of stats does that
bring that up yeah he's mad here yeah so
games and um running stats as a team
individuals
uh high speed running diesel excels um
he's good on things like that and he has
a good team around him um good
nutritionist and everything with him who
who helped you and we've got they've got
a good team there and i hope he's just
feeding them chips and gravy so that's a
relief how's my bacon did you say that
you don't mind it's called toilet quick
yeah yeah you guys
thank you
obviously um you went to the euros 2021
i was supposed to be 2020 but obviously
what happened happened and
you
weren't in the same role you played a
different role
uh came on left back at one point then
set up
shaw's goal in the final yeah and you
know was uh i think you played did you
play three games in that tournament one
of the other you were on then off then
on yeah right you're on and off when
yeah i was on like in and out yeah yeah
and kind of like what you were saying
before you like it was important for you
then because you weren't starting to
have that positive attitude did you see
that as part of the responsibility of
what you were doing or yeah because
uh obviously i'm up against so much
competition so it's it's difficult never
knowing it be like this that's the most
competitive place right i'd say i'd say
so in the in in the squad yeah my squad
yeah the amount of like england back in
the day it was like strikeouts we had
like shira nicole ian wright ferdinand
fowler yeah sharing them yeah now is
right back we've got like 10 class right
back yeah exactly yeah yeah how you guys
are looking at each other is everyone
sort of going good to see you glad you
could come you know no it's not you're
like that really it's obviously me and
walks i've known each other for
since was like on day 18's in england
anyway so we've known each other for
ages and obviously was that tottenham
together but obviously we've rhys at the
time and uh and obviously trent
we all have a great relationship anyway
i know
i'm not just saying that but we do you
know and that's the the chemistry we
have away with england everybody gets on
with everybody regardless of who's in
each of his position but
um yeah it's difficult because there's
so many right backs now um but no it's
good you know you need competition you
want
you want competition so you know you're
on your toes every day in training you
know you want to you want to be showing
why you should be playing and that's
what every single one of us do are
competitive does gareth chat to you so
you know when you first get there do you
get individual chats with him do you get
group chats with him and like who's
going into
how much you'll play what's your who's
managing your expectation as an england
player well for me it's not like anybody
else you don't come and tell you you're
gonna play like soon as you go to camp
it's obviously you need to train well
so
but no he's brilliant he does have
individual meeting with the players and
that's what's so good about him his man
management is brilliant with everybody
not just myself he's done a lot for me
on and off the field and you know i
respect i respect that and i respect him
but um nice is a quality of my manager
and a manager as well him and steve
island have a great chemistry together
um in training and everything but um
nice
every meeting that he does individual as
a group it's
it's good how long before an england
game do you find out whether or not
you're playing because in these
tournaments they come thick and fast
yeah yeah sometimes it's more like
probably day before a game where you're
doing like the the set pieces and stuff
like that you'll know the team
um yeah and obviously you do the set
pieces wherever you're up against and
then get ready but you need to need to
make sure that you're always ready to
play because anything can happen how did
you get so good at set pieces
nice
i won't say i'm the best you're
definitely high on the list or you know
i i always do my best but it's more
from when it's a lot yeah especially
when i was younger when i was at man
city going through the youth team i had
a great coach called uh steve ah
um you done a lot with me but it's just
all about practicing and having that
responsibility to take them
um and yeah it's just something i've
always worked on even now it's pretty
well i mean and then so you're in the
tournament and he comes to you and he
goes
left back
yeah um
we've done a meehan um
it's funny enough i can't i'm trying to
think now was it
i'm trying to think was the meeting when
he named the team that was going to play
before we did set pieces anyway uh
my name come on walks his name cooper so
far all right i won't be playing and
karen trippier come up laughing oh where
am i playing her
playing up front
have you played left back much before
that it was more i played there for
tottenham before um
you know when somebody's gone off you
know pochettino pushed me there um
but no you know it's i think it's more
gareth really who's
he's putting there on a more free
frequent basis really and not for me i
don't mind it uh like i said
play me anyway if i can help the team
i'll help the team if it's on the bench
or from left back or right back and he
actually made quite a big deal about
this he was like you know afterwards he
was like if i if that had gone wrong
it's clearly yeah i'm dead like as in
it's all on me there's no
you know people can't share that
responsibility because i've clearly put
someone who is not in their right
position or natural position our
position yeah so did you feel that like
i can't let him down or did you were you
not even thinking about that honestly i
would even think about that because us
players and gareth we all not just me
all the players know they'll give
everything for the shirt and for him um
and for me it's i played there he's had
the trust in me for to play against
belgium there and uh and i feel like i
can do a job there obviously i'm not a
natural left-back boy i can i can do a
job there and um and yeah it worked out
we won we won the game and
everything was fine what does it feel
like to lose
the euro final it was really tough to
take obviously with
playing at wembley the the way
everything went the whole tournament um
yeah and to lose it on penalties was
you know it hurt us of course and as you
guys i imagine
um
yeah it was tough to take really it was
tough that was it was probably one of
the few things that could have a better
the uh legal uh medal like yeah
yeah winning trophy for england yeah
this is the thing though you guys have
gone further than anyone has gone before
uh since 66. so
there's a lot to be taken from that what
was the mood like afterwards obviously
you were low but what kind of things
were you guys saying to each other
because some people i feel like you are
quite a strong guy you can take it in
your stride other people maybe it's not
so much so yeah was there anyone who you
remember taking it worse and what people
would say to them or everyone's
different different character obviously
i was i was gutted um as as everybody
was
um
yeah it was just a bit it went silent
you know um a few of the
experienced pros like hurricane maguire
you know who said a few things in the
dressing room um which was which was
really good i think in that specific
moment it was it was good for them to
step up and the way they did and ex and
do the speech
yeah it was tough it was tough to take
because we was there you know penalties
um
but no you see the like i said you see
the progress that we've made from the
world cup to the euros
made huge steps we've got to be proud
you know the most important thing for us
we've connected again with the
supporters and that was massive from
back in the day to now i feel like we
have that good chemistry you know yeah
the feeling has definitely changed yeah
yeah we i think i remember sitting
around this table when we were watching
and and us all saying like
this is the first time in a long time
where we could we feel
because you guys are millionaires and
money doesn't like change you completely
but it makes you feel further away to us
and i know that you seem a lot more keen
in
not being so untouchable and unreachable
uh from what you've said to me before
the podcast but
some footballers they feel like
fictional
yeah god like yeah and and
it felt like the first time in a while
where
the lads became the lads and a bit like
us and living our dreams and not
the vibe changed yeah definitely i think
that's important um
and we felt that as players as well
obviously it's brilliant for us to
play the games and then we win and then
we see like you guys celebrating you
know i mean and the supporters throwing
pints in there and
we feel good you know that we're you
guys are celebrating and enjoying the
moment it was a great journey you know
england was you know that the whole
country was
crazy weren't it you know and
that he was saying in russia when was
there as well when you know high part
when all the pines have grown up and
everything is mad but it's good to see
you
we that's what we want we want to put
smiles on people's faces and
um you know be winning games for all our
supporters to be celebrated
um so yeah i think that
i think we've connected really well over
the years funny story right uh we were
on a uh we were we were we had a
sponsorship back then
in
2018 where
we
we only got as many games from the
sponsors england got so i knew every
time england won we got an extra x
amount of money yeah and it was in the
thousands of pounds you know it was
keeping the business going at the time
absolutely right so
when that
when that free kick goes
i was on the roof yeah
um so it wasn't just uh making people
happy it was literally keeping us in a
job literally yeah um but yeah thanks
for that you mentioned harry kane and
him giving that speech and
you know what a what a plan mcguire as
well yeah yeah mcguire sorry but
on harry kane like uh
he's
he's such a player but um he's had all
this focus around his career especially
in the last year and a half when that
big move nearly happened
um
what's your thoughts on
a club keeping a player who openly
wants to go somewhere else well h first
i'll say is the most professional player
i've ever played with right so you know
obviously it it didn't happen in the
summer but he's one of those where
he's not going to throw his toys out of
the prom that city performance was
pretty special wasn't it yeah and
that's what he does you know people
look at his goals or
when he doesn't score for example when
the media was on his back a little bit
um people need to look at how he brings
people like sunny into play when he
drops deep and he's playing them
diagonal passes and
he's just
such a good player are you guys um so
even when you're not together obviously
in england camp you're obviously still
mate someone's going to show the phone
numbers are you all in different
whatsapp groups with each other
you know what i have we have a couple of
whatsapp groups of lads from england um
and yeah before we play pixel i was
texting him as well you know
i mean
like me and pixar
best mates oh really yeah i mean pixar's
so close like little t-rex
you see you can't laugh at that you
can't do anything yeah but it's
hilarious seeing did you see the
dinosaurs someone had in in the chrome
cinephone yeah but he's a great guy yeah
i know you're great
yeah but he's he's a great guy like him
um
yeah he's one of my best piles but yeah
i've texted him before that before the
games leading up to it and now and
you know he took my goal well to refer
to my speaking him after it and yeah he
is now basically their representative in
the premier league and whenever
he comes to saying james i've never
known a player takes so much [__] in my
life credit um like because it's nice
yeah you're under pressure as it is
you're also stuck there so it's not like
you could you know you're going up and
down the line you're in front of like 10
000 people yeah great guy pixie's one of
those where he loved banter some of the
boys like the long staff brothers was
was speaking to me about like
uh the banter picks out for the
newcastle fans and stuff and
did that they're always on him when he's
there and i and i even when i was
playing when he's like every time you
have the ball and stuff i've never heard
anything like it but yeah and he gives
it back you know he has banner you know
and a fair player to picks like you know
how conscious of you are you of that as
a player like can you hear people in the
crowd or are you sort of like it's all
just one thing yeah to be fair like when
the
when my teammates when the lads were
telling me about like
listen to the sticker get so
honestly when i was playing i was like
every time you got the ball so i was
trying to list like closely like you
zone like in games sometimes you don't
realize the crowd's there so i was
trying to focus in like every time i got
it
my word like he was getting some bro
every time he got the ball and like
there was one in there
one in the second half i think he was
yes i can have one he he's like tried to
side valet he shanked it oh yeah i don't
remember it and then the center after
it's kicked in and kicked out for a
corner hilarious and then i spoke to him
after the game about it but he was just
like you know just laughing and joking
about it you know he's had the odd
nightmare after james's like it's up i
remember one game where he couldn't
handle it and nothing because i think i
went so close to my computer
it all went right it all went this is
guys yeah sorry i'd take photos it it
all went and uh
but since then i think now he's like
brace for it but in my head when i watch
him i'm thinking we should be shooting
from every single chance we get because
i i i i 100 bullying and actually uh
that was the thing about
the relegation scrap when i watched
everton i'm thinking
frank lampod what do you know about a
trap a relegation battle no offense to
the guy like obviously a hell of a
footballer but they say in his sort of
domain and i'm looking at these everton
players feeling sorry for themselves in
my opinion and i'm looking at joel and
like a battering ram i'm looking at our
team
bullying them and i thought you lot
don't look like you fancy this
relegation scrap like um
no i've been in it before when i was at
burnley you know um
obviously when you're in in this
position it's no way like you said it's
it's it's a dog fight you know and
you know before you know it
be april you know and then may yeah
we'll come into the season so
one of the funny things that eddie how
was criticized for
which made me laugh was people were
going um
oh well he's he's only been in a
relegation scrapped once and he went
down and i'm like you do realize he's
manager of bournemouth yeah five years
yeah yeah that's one long relegation
people miss i think they misunderstood
that he over-performed as a manager for
so many years and obviously you know
yeah you got relegated with bournemouth
but um
you know what a what a good stint he had
there and they've done really well yeah
i feel i feel
a lot of the fans when you watch a
manager's interview you're wanting this
to feel like
there's a guy who's
who's calm but has an edge to him who's
sensible but has
um that ability to act in in a time of
need and that's what's quite interesting
as well is obviously you had him earlier
in your career and now you've got them
again you notice a difference yeah
definitely i feel
um from when i first started mobs house
i was younger than just after when i
went to barnsley so
i was there uh
i feel like now he's more
he's more aware of like the way his
style because
before i um
signed for newcastle he was in madrid
watching us train you know um because he
said he studied the game for a couple of
years he was out for a couple of years
yeah and then he texted me he not him
jason tindall texted me
probably
early october just before then saying
how can we come and watch your train so
i was like yeah no worries then they
came out just to watch how we
started simeone trains basically but it
weren't just because he went to a few
other clubs and he was studying other
teams and
that just shows his commitment the type
of manager that he is because he'll be
a top manager i have no doubt about that
in the future so um
yeah it is is you can see he's is
obsessed as well you know um i've heard
that if we don't do a drill properly no
no do it again don't do it properly no
no we're doing it again you know so he's
very good manager
i've got that uh colin wilson's injured
yeah this kid is another one who i
didn't realize how good he was until he
played for newcastle because you
naturally you don't watch every 90
minutes of every other club
and
you know
uh unfortunately he's had some injury
worries but when i see him fully fit i
think wow if you could stay fit for a
full season and get even okay so yes
you're we're looking at a top striker
there he is he's uh even when he had
that um he had to spell as well when he
came away with england with us as well
and he got a goal as well i think it was
against uh
usa i think it
no but carl's shown throughout his
career as a goal scorer obviously
uh he's out injured at the moment but
again he's another one who's still
positive still he's a joker of the
dressing room jeremy and even now like
but i know and i can say that he's
working hard
to get back um quality player such a
finisher what about uh your time i
suppose then yeah because obviously uh
it
he went all the way to the champions
league final and this is a consistent
thing in your career is obviously you're
a winner you've you've you've done some
great things but um it didn't it didn't
go your way but what what a what a
journey that was i remember that seven
was it the semi-finals
i'll make it sure but of the group stage
we had into barcelona
and uh um into barcelona and i think psv
or something like that
and
everyone was saying it was impossible
that would qualify in the group we had
to be into a home and away we did we had
to get a result away to barcelona we did
we qualified so we got rolled off from
the start basically
um and yeah we played city and then braz
i think it was razzy scores the last
second
and then he was called offside
was on the floor devastating i was going
to say what's it like being in the
stadium and then that's the first time
where like a var type situation sort of
created really that was crazy because i
took the corner for um lorenzo to score
and people said come off his arm which i
think it did but he could have done
anything about it and then
two minutes later russ scores and now
we're thinking oh my god it's dover it's
done with and it's offside and you're
thinking
hold on you know because you played city
away yeah the iraq's one were mad like
lucas comes up with bags and hat trick
she's in the second half
and as soon as he's got the third we're
thinking no way has this happened no way
that final
it it felt like a really strange fight
laurence as a liverpool fan sorry about
that i don't think do you agree though
do you think it were a penalty
um oh yeah there's no debate in my mind
absolutely no be honest um
because mani chips it and book i get
what you're saying suzuka's already made
himself big it's one of the ones it's
technically a penalty but it's not a
penalty and so those rules are like they
apply those rules in a really stupid way
and that's where you want a good referee
in the final who goes well that's why i
don't see it that way that changed
everything and they understand the flow
of the game and stuff like that and i
think that's what ruined that final
really for for liverpool fans as well we
looked at that and obviously there's a
sense of relief for us yeah but it
didn't it it killed the stock it killed
the game and especially for you guys i
think because we'd you you guys were
very much you'd had that run it was like
right if they had the offsite
just because the way the city game went
the ayax game when we fought stories
exactly
we felt confident and then two minutes
into the game or whatever it was
we did get a penalty and i think that
just
killed the game
this is the thing though yeah from a
fan's point of view
you're looking thinking
if you're gonna concede
the opening five minutes is yeah
but you've got so much that game left
but it looked as if it
mentally
drained you guys
no of course the second minute when we
go one note down and then but even in
the game i thought okay what are the
prettiest of games was it really [__]
not tall champions league finale you're
expecting
mate you should try playing in the game
if you're playing in the game try
talking about that stuff yeah this is
really hard you weren't they weren't the
best one of the best and entertaining
that's not your fault we're not going to
get exactly yeah no no no i i agree with
you um
but yeah i thought we there were some
moments where four was on top of the
game but then when
obviously arrigay comes on and he bags
that second goal it's finished
the game is done
what was so different about that spurs
team do you think because spurs have got
this thing now where people say oh
spursy which is
to put it like what we've just seen in
the last month where they'll play
amazing against manchester united harry
kane looks untouchable and then in other
games they're just a shell of that
but in that season
spurs weren't supposed these spurs were
battlers they had quality there
especially there yeah they had spite
they had a nasty streak about them
which i think was what mourinho was
trying to get back into them when he
gave us a little speech there what they
need to be um
why were they so different that season i
don't know i i had to say really but
especially when poetry were with us we
was
like machines
not just the level everyone was just
machines because the way we trained and
stuff but
especially at wyatt
whiteheart lane as well was was tough to
beat the two years were was challenging
for the prem where the game at chelsea
which was absolutely just carnage like
that was where they're nearly fought
wasn't it like that oh yeah yeah they
did yeah yeah it was on the sidelines
yeah yeah it was the night in leicester
i was in leicester for that night i was
watching your game that was the season
that was the night they were goalless
yeah so you you you knew that game and
then there's a draw right to all was it
three two two well if it has our score
didn't it right hazard kill dude and
that was the night where everyone in
leicester was basically watching
and watching you guys fight it was kind
of wild i think the wonderful that
killed us when the year leicester won
the league is when they beat us at home
robert who scores two goals two headers
i think it was two headers that is like
mentalism and if we win that game then
it changes everything you know but i'm
not saying we would have won the league
but he would for sure change something
what was it what was posh like it's a
manager because you said you would have
you would have
appreciated an arm around the shoulder
when you were going through that rough
patch yeah and he's i think the jury is
very much still out on what level he's
at because at spurs he had this heir of
the next big manager yeah didn't win
anything then he goes to psg um
and it hasn't it's not been the right
cocktail it just hasn't quite happened
for him like and players who even we you
know we'd expect to be performing well
messi isn't having the time of his life
there for example
has not been this difficult to manage
that isn't it was his style because
you've talked about
brilliant now he was
more to say on the front foot he was
more
machines safe was playing like a man
city okay or whoever the the
he used to analyze it the way i analyzed
it and took it onto the training field
and the amount of time was on there
just mimicking the way city played and
stuff it was he went into so much detail
you know i think expecting people to be
like machines and going into detail
about the opposition so much and that
that isn't the paris way is it really
well if you look at it there it's it's
the individuals a lot in it you've got
neymar messi
[Music]
so it's pretty tricky to manage that set
it is you know and
it's i think it's hard for a manager
because
yeah it's just about keeping them happy
i guess isn't it well you know you said
one of the best things about simeone is
that
he is larger than life at that club and
he has so much command so much respect
but when you're trying to tell neymar
who's got some contract where you get a
hotel if he scores a goal or whatever
but yeah but often
i don't care what player it is you
wouldn't get away without sitting on it
you don't care who you are exactly yeah
and it's tricky when you're then going
into work
yeah yeah who
when you're met with these massive
players
it's easier for the chairman to go yeah
would you change your manager so where
is your
where's your what are you trading off of
here yeah where's your value yeah i'll
just
it's half me to to answer that how he is
with them of course it's difficult but
have you seen a a player
throw a bit of a [__] fit you know
where they they're having a bit of a
moment where they think they're too good
for something or they're they're they're
a bit well you've looked at someone and
thought you were getting too big for
your boots here you don't have to name
and shame
you see when that happened i was trying
to think
well they said to think that they're
better than as in like i'm gaffa i'm not
doing that i'm sorry like but um because
i've like where you had kieran dyer on
the on the show love kieran great guy
but he said when he was in his prime he
admitted he was a bit of a knob through
his weight around a bit you know bobby
robson would say are you going to play
this position you say i'm not playing
that position you know like oh i've
never really come across anything like
that where if a manager says
you're playing this picture i've never
really come across stuff like that but
uh maybe
maybe in training maybe if a player
doesn't agree with the manager or
whatever i've seen i've seen that the
bus stops how do you see matt
it's quite interesting because obviously
there's also going to be people who
think they know what gets the best out
of them so you know there's that
contrast of like well you're here to do
what i want to do yeah but i'll score
goals or i'll get crosses in if i do
this
i would never ever second guess
my manager right if he wants me to do
something i'll do it so
there might come a time where i think
well i could maybe do a little i could
do better in how would you approach that
you tried a private chat instead of
yeah i wouldn't i'd never challenge my
manager but if
it's not like i might disagree with if i
just think i can be better doing this in
this instance i'll say something but i
won't i'll just ask him his opinion you
know and if he feels it's right he's
right if he doesn't i'll do whatever he
expects me to do we're getting a little
uh saying that or rapper you've got a
couple of minutes yeah yeah it's fine uh
why do you think
you know you come through the youth
system and all of that i'm sure you've
seen loads of talented lads who maybe
didn't make it what made you different
to a lot of those people that you were
growing up with
that's a good question
um i played when i was at man city there
was obviously me sturridge
bent me at the time and i had a really
really good youth team but
t question it's hard to say really i
think but more about your personality
than anything i'm wondering what you
think makes you
the the person as well as the player i
think having the right people around me
was important you know like my brother
he used to play
football league and stuff and
i think he's having the right people
around you you know um not too many
people who are telling you how great you
are when you've had a bad game or do you
know what i mean and
you know you want people around you who
said oh you could have done better today
i have a lot of friends like that uh i
remember when i got absolutely ripped
once by antonio chef wednesday against
burnley i said i played all right today
no no he went hannah you were [__]
you know what i mean but i like that you
know i like my friends like that and
they are they're brutal with me yeah my
brother as well so um yeah most
important thing i think is having the
right people around you um
yeah and like i've known so many players
who don't play now so many quality
players yeah
people to take different paths you know
um you seem very dedicated yeah i am i
feel like i am yeah i feel like i'm i'm
dedicated for sure quite level-headed
treating your ups and downs in a very
similar way i think through the
experiences that i've had you know i've
like have yeah maybe i've been doubted
throughout my career i feel like you are
an unlikely hero that's like a newcastle
but we're very grateful to have you now
i'm delighted to be here honestly i am
no i am and
hopefully there's many more exciting um
chapters ahead for us you better believe
it i mean jesus i do believe it yeah
yeah this is crazy what's your what's
your
couple more questions what's your belief
in terms of where the club is headed
given
you have had probably conversations with
the gaffer and yeah amanda stavely and
and uh murad and people like that like
what what kind of vision is being
put to use if we stay up we need to
build
and then build again and build again and
then go for the title that's it that's
what we want final question how would
you like to be remembered
at newcastle uh in your career
good question again it's just more
a player that uh
gave everything um
never shied away from a challenge
which i've i've done a couple of times
like coming here the position newcastle
was in going out to atletico madrid
um and just the the play that gave
everything
i like gave everything for
every team that i played for so
ian right give a very similar answer
yeah i appreciate that mate it's been an
absolutely
it's a lot easier to talk about your
career when it's obviously it's being
gone and i know that you know you're in
a position here where you're getting a
lot of different questions and it's a
long-form interview not something that
plays a lot a lot of the time literally
it's five minutes after the game most of
the time cheers see you later yeah i
don't mind that you don't mind it at all
mate honestly no thanks for having me
i've loved it the fans have taken you
massively yeah that is kind of crazy
isn't it now brian normally hates the
newcastle squad so this is weird
you know there's been a lot of years
where to be fair you've had good reason
in previous years this is the first time
i've ever seen like brian actually go i
think i might watch the game today
it's exciting
what i mean by that is brian normally
goes yeah we got the game this afternoon
i think yeah i think we'll watch it and
now he's more like game's on in a minute
are we are we on we're ready to go so
it's quite funny i'm feeling all
together that's good it's not about
winning and losing it's just the energy
you lads are uh applying to that to the
to the games though it's something that
the fans are really proud of and it
represents please and honestly the
players will appreciate that and the
players must want to give good
performances as you've been seeing and
want to be successful to to make the
city buzzing again so now the players
will would appreciate good luck between
now and the end of the season because i
mean like i said it it keeps us uh in a
good business as well i appreciate it
honestly no thank you for having me
thank you that was kieran trippier on
the true geordie podcast england right
back newcastle right back even now we
don't need to wait for people to retire
anymore they come on while they're doing
it thanks very much for watching hit the
like button subscribe and we'll see you
later cheers